uh i want to look at um just a kind of a
i don't want to say this is the final
kind of coda on this story but
we're kind of closing the loop on this
classified documents thing that we've
been covering regarding donald trump uh
glenn kirschner a legal analyst said on
msnbc that donald trump is facing a
five-year felony over the classified
documents scandal as you now
may know we've covered it a couple of
times donald trump did indeed take
classified documents to mar-a-lago to
his house those were since recovered by
the national archives and the full
story has been turned over to the
justice department for criminal
investigation here is glenn kirschner
appearing on msnbc talking about the
legal liability here and remember faces
five years is very different than
something will happen but let's listen
glenn the judge's ruling says quote to
deny a president immunity from civil
damages is no small step the court well
understands the gravity of its decision
but the alleged facts of this case are
without precedent your reaction
my reaction is donald trump may be
reaching the end of his rope i agree
with paul that there is i think a
hesitation among prosecutors both state
and federal nobody wants to be the first
one to charge a former president who's
committed any number of crimes i predict
jonathan once the first brave prosecutor
who has the evidence to indict donald
trump brings that indictment everybody's
going to want to be the second
prosecutor so that's that's interesting
first and foremost because we've been
talking about this
i guess we might say hesitation to kind
of cross the rubicon because there's
this
again it's not a policy it's sort of
just like a um
an unspoken agreement i don't even know
what to call it there's this tradition
of not charging american presidents
current or former
but this is a unique circumstance in
that there are so many different reasons
why trump might get charged but yet i
think kirschner is right kushner is
often hyperbolic he's made predictions
that haven't haven't come true so you
know take that all with a grain of salt
there is some degree to which it makes
sense that no one prosecutor would want
to be the first to charge a former
president um then let's move on to where
he talks about the five-year felony
glenn is switching topics just a little
bit how can the january 6 committee use
the information that donald trump took
classified documents to further its
investigation
yeah that is a five-year felony the
national archives has reported and
referred to the department of justice
for investigation the fact that donald
trump removed classified national
security information from the white
house and he whisked it away to
mar-a-lago jonathan if that were you or
me or paul you can bet we'd already be
indicted now that part is absolutely
true for a number of the different
things trump has done normal people
so-called would absolutely have been
indicted already but again
faces a five-year felony is very
different than anything is likely to
happen i would love it if the evidence
points to charges and a conviction for
trump i would love for that to happen if
that's what due process determines but i
still do not believe trump will see any
jail or prison time period wake me up
when he actually faces some consequences
he's been dodging all sorts of legal
entanglements for i mean listen
certainly the five six years since he
started running for president but even
longer than that when you consider the
trump organization and at a sort of
basic gut check level
think about the absurdity of trump as
president has the ability to declassify
anything he wants he could have just
declassified the stuff that he wanted to
take he doesn't and instead he just
takes it without declassifying it and
now he has stolen classified documents
the most logical explanation that i've
seen
is the documents are worth more still
classified they're worth more money but
that's a crazy explanation but it's also
the most reasonable explanation in the
sense that what trump did doesn't make
any sense will he face consequences i
doubt it but there are now multiple
criminal and civil investigations
georgia new york justice department
looking at the documents the stuff with
the trump organization and the
misstatement of the values of assets
this this it it's going to be years
and
maybe trump's best bet at getting out
from under all of it
is to run for president in 2024 and win
which is yet another reason why we have
to be prepared for him to try to do that
again
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years
privacy lets me create virtual payment
cards with one click and when i use the
virtual card the money is taken out of
my bank account you can create multiple
cards delete them freeze them set a
spending limit on them let's say i'm
signing up for a free trial and it
requires a credit card privacy will
autofill a virtual card number and then
after signing up i can delete that
virtual card so i know i'm not going to
be charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video